when colonial powers grab territory it
usually stays separate from the lands of
the metropole india was a part of the
british empire but not a part of britain
the philippines were a part of the
spanish empire but not spain but when
the french first conquered algeria it
wasn't long until it was incorporated
into france proper not as a colony but
just as much a part of france as
normandie or corsica and given just how
irregular this was why did france do
this why was algeria a part of france
itself and not a colony so as of 1827
this region was known as the regency of
algiers which officially was an ottoman
puppet state but realistically it was
independent during the napoleonic wars
algias had provided food for napoleon's
armies and 25 years later its leaders
were calling in the debt france said no
tempers fled and king charles the tenth
blockaded the country to get its leaders
to submit they did not this problem was
timed well for king charles who was in a
bit of trouble back at home and so to
divert attention away from him he
ordered the invasion of the region the
algae's military was defeated quickly
but guerilla-style resistance would
carry on long afterwards in case you're
wondering this expedition did little for
charles since he would be gone soon
afterwards but his successor louis
philippe would oversee the conquest of
these lands until 1848 which was a year
in which well stuff happened one of
these stuff was when king louis philippe
was unkingified and the second french
republic was proclaimed a new republican
constitution was drafted which
importantly proclaimed that these areas
in algeria were formerly a part of
france the primary reason for this was
that the creators of the constitution
were worried that the ongoing
instability in france could end up
losing them algeria they were concerned
that either the ottomans or another
european power would make an attempt to
take it from them or that whoever was
appointed to govern it may side against
the government if there was another
revolution as such it was divided into
three administrative sections and made a
formal part of the country and you would
expect that as an integral part of this
new republic the algerians would be
given the same rights as any other
frenchman but fun fact no despite being
a part of france proper citizenship was
reserved for two groups those called the
piedmoist the descendants of french and
european settlers and in 1870 after
napoleon iii reformed the government
algeria's native jewish population there
were two reasons for this the first was
money since the jewish algerians would
be expected to pay taxes to fund things
like wars against prussia and second by
making hundreds of thousands of
algerians french he gave the mistake in
preserving french rule there meaning
that there would be allies if things
ever got interesting the muslims of
algeria got nothing and were only
considered to be french subjects and
they were by and large treated the exact
same as the natives in any other french
colony like in neighboring tinier or
morocco so what changed well the process
of france losing algeria was a slow one
there were no attempts to placate or
help the native muslims of the region
until it became clear that there was a
risk of losing algeria for good at first
it was believed that the ideals of the
french revolution and the superiority of
french culture were so obvious that the
native population would slowly but
surely assimilate and become french
themselves shockingly this didn't happen
but after two world wars the french
population wanted to recognize the
contributions of algerians to the wars
thus in 1947 the french government gave
citizenship and thus voting rights to
muslims in algeria too late for any of
that though since many of those living
there wanted the french gone and so it
was time for war the french fought
incredibly hard to keep the colony since
it didn't want to abandon the idea of
its civilizing mission nor did it want
to accept that it couldn't defend the
french living in algeria the problem was
that bullets don't care about your pride
and once the death toll started to rise
it became clear that france couldn't
hold the territory numerous governments
fell over the issue and in the end it
was only charles de gaulle whose
prestige allowed him to admit defeat and
retain any popularity that algeria's
position as a formal part of france came
to an end i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker corso wolf
adam stalter jerry landon jordan longley
rod d martin wyan hockey gustav swan
spencer lightfoot captain cydog winston
k wood boogery wiggly marvin castle
aaron the white words about books
podcast communion matthew shipley max
and flaudio alex schwinn maggie
patzkowski marcus asner the muck whopper
corey turner anthony beckett copper tone
spinning three plates charles the first
ben evanson and scottish trekkie